schaar lewinsky ist zurück am ort seiner
kindheit in seiner primarschule in
zürich herrscht stolz auf praktische
wachse 65 jahre ist es her seit er hier
zur schule gegangen ist levinsky trifft
auf sie selbst als bub den ort hat er
gewählt um über seinen neuen roman zu
sprechen
darin kreiert er eine horror fiktion
die hauptfigur andersen muss eine
zusatzrunde auf dem karussell des lebens
drehen
er kommt noch einmal auf die welt als
baby mit den eigenschaften und
erinnerungen eines alten mannes prinz
ihre hilflose trainerin aber mit dem
bewusst sie stand von excel erstellen
andersen ist kein freundlicher mensch
der mozart liebhaber ekelt sich vor der
bunten welt in die er hineingeboren wird
immer wieder betonte wie sehr er seine
eltern verachten
arno und helene auf jeden fall sind
durchschnittsware nichts besonderes 70
und hat mühe
das böse kind übernimmt das kommando
frei nach dem motto jeder mensch lässt
sich erzielt der autor lässt die jungen
eltern total scheitern
wir waren mit mir indisch sich sehr
fertig aufgebaut
sie haben 25 21 und charakter und
unendlich haben andere dann sind auch
senioren sind auf drogen hat man es
eigentlich schon richtig machen
lustig wir hatten die autobild league
hätte so hätte so aufgestellt
in diesem raum hat charlie winski mit
dem schreiben begonnen
wir schreiben immer zu mir gehört
geblieben ist sein antrieb seine
unstillbare neugier darauf fremde leben
und welten zu erfinden lewinsky sagt
selbstbewusst mit zunehmendem alter
werde er ein immer besserer
schriftsteller bringt ja sehr viel ob
bewusst oder unbewusst für sich selber
mit
für das muss man klar und erlebte hätte
das buch wie jetzt anderen hätte ich mit
reese kinder kleine schrieb nagano opfer
der wohl größte nun mit fast 70 hatte er
eines tages plötzlich die iba zu
andersen eine geschichte voller
verstörender parallelen zwischen baby
und kreis beide sind abhängig vom
wohlwollen anderer felski ein
horrorszenario
reals problem
sicher fehlen wird und wann sie in der
hilflosigkeit rutschen vor allem lügt
uns ganz auf ständig sie sind wo es aber
bestimmt an dann plötzlich von der
schwester mit einer riesengroßen zeit
mit euch jetzt was herr müller
grauenhafte vorstellung
wie düster und böse andersen wirklich
ist wurde auch dem schriftsteller selbst
erst beim schreiben bewusst was für ihn
aber lange vorher klar war zum
siebzigsten wollte er einen neuen roman
herausbringen
das hatte er seinem verleger schon vor
drei jahren angekündigt definitiv auf
das konzentriert was man früher einmal
gemacht hat und medium weil man sich auf
das konzentriert was man vorhat wie die
auszahlung hat das gar nichts tue ich
kann also uralte 3 jährige